all right guys hear me out slavery is
bad but I'm constantly on a journey to
find the next great anime the next great
manga and nowadays we are spoiled for
Choice recently I just finished Vinland
Saga season 2 which is a masterpiece
that shook me to my core a human story
so powerful it can not only give you a
great experience it can change your
outlook on life it's shows like these
that remind me why I love the medium so
much but on this NeverEnding Journey
some days I wake up and I remember wait
a minute I'm
[Music]
a cuz what if I've told you that I've
discovered a high intensity Shonen
action manga with amazing art about
being a slave to an army of insane anime
girls in military uniforms that can kick
your ass and will find any way shape or
form to sit in your face every other
chapter now I know what you're going to
say G God damn it what do you think I am
some weird perverted freak can you
please stop trying to get me into your
weird hentti fetish
[__] so what's the name of the manga
again point is there are times I want to
remind people that I'm always striving
to find the next anime or Manga
Masterpiece and prove to the world that
I'm still a functional member of society
then I remember that I play hongkai Star
hi I'm gig and just in case you needed a
monthly reminder that I'm still a piece
of garbage here's a manga about being
stepped on by H anime
girls
before we get stepped on by degeneracy
why don't we step on over to today's
sponsor pubg mobile pubg mobile is an
extremely popular free Battle Royale
shooter with eight different classic
maps and a plethora of different game
modes with the ability to compete in
team death matches classic battle Royals
arcade games and the new world of Wonder
creation mode where you can create and
play your very own Maps it's no wonder
this game continues to be a blast every
time I log in things have gotten even
better with their 2.7 update where pubg
mobile paired with one of the most
iconic anime of all time Dragon Ball
super not only does this Mark the first
time Dragon Ball super has teamed up
with a mobile only game but their
collaboration has led to a variety of
amazing game perks that you don't want
to miss there's a new Dragon Ball super
themed game mode that allows you to
discover new areas built to replicate
famous locations from the series like
Dragon Ball Village teni budai KEH house
and Karan Tower you can even collect all
seven Dragon Balls to receive powerful
in-game Buffs not forgetting you can
also gain access to new skills and items
like the Kamehameha powerful key move
send sub beans to help restore your
health the dragon radar which helps you
to collect and find Dragon Balls the Hoy
air car and more you can even use key to
upgrade your materials which will come
in handy while playing the new Dragon
Ball Super Battle Royale mode here you
can play as characters like Sun Goku
Vegeta Frieza Piccolo and ultimate Gohan
use their unique skills in battle and
strive to be the last one standing
within this new map and mode guys you do
not want to miss this 2.7 update
especially if you're a Dragon Ball Super
Fan or just a fan of great games in
general so just click the link in the
description to download and start
playing pubg mobile for free today thank
you very much to pubg mobile for
sponsoring me today and back to the
video all right before you start raising
your eyebrows at me I just want to say I
did not go out looking for a manga like
this this manga just happened to find me
your honor see I was just innocently
browsing my local manga store when a
manga cover caught my eye of a military
clad smug anime girl looking down at me
emanating the purest step on me energy
man could ask for with a single massive
word plasted behind her slave and my
brain went
huh M say no slave or chain Soldier asks
a simple philosophical question to all
the guys in the world would you sell
your dignity to be stepped on by a group
of hot anime girl yes in the manga's
fictional apocalyptic year of 2020 a
dangerous Dimension called mat merges
all over Japan bringing with them
monsters that terrorize the world and
cause various disasters fortunately with
these monsters have come a new tool
Humanity can use to combat them peaches
I'm my serious resource that can give
humans Supernatural Powers they can
wield but granting these abilities to
women and only women causing a male
female Power Balance to be completely
flipped on his head men are now at the
lower end of the social hierarchy and
Andrew Tate has become Andrew cake enter
Yuki Waka uh male who's one day just
minding his own business when he
suddenly finds himself in a life or
death situation in the mat realm facing
off against an army of monsters
thankfully Humanity has created a
specialized combat Squad of superpowered
peach girls called the anti- demon core
and the commander of the seventh unit
sweeps in just in time to save the day
this is kyoka usen who has the ability
to make slaves which I know sounds
pretty bad
but so anyway she offers him the
opportunity to submit to her which
allows him to activate his ultimate
ability
slavery just I can't transforming him to
the super powerful combat form that can
decimate the monster Army this gives him
the chance to be the hero he always
wanted to be but unfortunately men can't
technically join the anti-demon Corp but
as a because they found a little
loophole he joins the seventh unit and
moves into their all female residence to
the dismay of all the girls that live
there and has to prove it worth by
becoming their caretaker being a
stay-at-home dad doing the housework and
cooking up a mean meal in the kitchen
it's got that secret
ingredient
oohoo and what's that come okay I know
that description makes it sound like
it's some weird Haram etchy [__] but
hear me out it's good weird Haram ety
[__] this is a manga written by the same
guy who did oh oh no but okay regardless
of your opinions of aiga kill and God
knows I have my opinions I think there's
one thing we can all come together to
agree on as
death was Bloody
hot so imagine a get killed but every
girl is a different flavor of s death
and replace all the edgy violence and
character deaths with s TI horny that's
mat no slave it's been a long time since
I've enjoyed an ety Series this much and
yes there is more that goes into a good
ety series I and just slapping some sexy
anime girls in your face and calling it
a day just because you appreciate anime
titties doesn't mean you can't do it
with a little bit of class I may be a
degenerate but I'm a degenerate with
standards I'm not one to watch a show
with nothing but fan service and ety
scenes at a selling point maybe that
would have worked when I was a dumbass
14-year-old kid but [__] there's
this thing called hentai it's like chy
but without the blue balling and it's
art if I'm going to watch a show there
needs to be another hook nice action an
interesting World a compelling romance
plot but another equally important thing
is how you implement the fan service in
your show you can't just show me thick
anime thighs and expect sorry I got
distracted you can't just show me thick
animy thighs and expect me to be
impressed and one thing I absolutely
despise is when the fan service gets in
the way of the action nothing quite
kills an action scene faster than when
you're fully invested in a fight it's
exciting you're into it your heart is
pounding the next big punch is about to
be thrown then the series goes all right
pause for a second anime
titties all right I'm back to the action
if you're going to put a bit of fan
service in your show keep it separate or
in the best case work with it fan
service should be the spice on your dish
and you know I'm a good boy from
Thailand I don't just like a little bit
of spice my food I love a lot of spice
but that doesn't mean I just want to eat
a plate full of Carolina Reapers nor
would I appreciate you squirting a
bottle of chili sauce on my dish when
that dish is a nice cool vanilla ice
cream but luckily mat SEO slave knows
exactly how and when to spice up his
dish see the twist to kyoko's Powers is
that after every battle she needs to
give
a reward to a slave that's proportional
to the they just exerted while she
activated her power with her completely
losing control of her body and her body
fully willing her actions until the
reward has been completely played out
and let's just say these rewards do my
Southeast Asian Heritage proud mama mia
that's a spicy what this means is that
the degeneracy never gets in the way of
the action in fact they work together to
enhance one another because the fan
service you get scales with the action
that precedes it there are some chapters
that give you just a quick and Casual
brawl that rewards you with just a
little tease just a little tickling of
the balls but it's it's when you get the
Epic multi-chapter Ark ending fights
there's the anticipation that as a
reader you know that once the battle is
over there is an equally epic high
intensity fullon degenerate etchy scene
from the gods waiting for you ladies and
gentlemen I present to you pavlovian
degeneracy I'm of the firm belief that
if you're going to go down the
degenerate route just fully commit you
think I a seasoned anime viewer I'm
impressed watching the millionth dense
protagonist accidentally walk into the
girl's changing room oh no [__] hintai
no and thankfully this series pulls no
punches in either its action or its
culture according to the law each reward
Yuki is given is based on his
subconscious desires and thankfully for
the readers our boy must be the average
genin impact player because he ain't
just bricked up he's the entire [__]
W Sig things off with just a vanilla
make out sesh as the series goes on the
rewards get more and more spicy like
he's cycling through the entire library
of hentai tags not a fan of the main
girl no worries the series introduces a
literal Army of dummy mommy Sean demons
wuss with weaponized thickness and here
come here let me give you a little bit
of a spoiler K can lend her powers out
to other girls you know what that means
I
have come but this goes into the one
thing mat say he does that separates it
from every other generic ety series it
has plot I'm not going to lie and say
that fan service isn't one of the main
selling points here but that doesn't
mean there's not more going for it as
well for one the action is actually
pretty kickass it goes beyond I'm going
to defeat you with the power of
friendship and titties each girl's
unique ability brings more dimension to
the action than just I'm I'm I'm going
to punch you I'm I'm going to punch you
really hard all the fights have their
own thoughts and tactics put into them
based on the powers of the present on
the playing field there's a girl who
literally just has Z World or that she
activates by doing a [__] JoJo pose
another girl has an ability called
python where she has to pre-program her
body movements like a goddamn software
engineer there's a
mil I can't remember what her powers are
and a similar level of thought has been
put into the characters and the general
world around them with a concept like
this it would have been easy just to
slap a bunch of cardboard cut out wfu
booves everywhere and throwing in some
nonsensical wacky plots whose only job
is to get from one etchy scene to the
next but each girl has their own
backstory and motivation that drives the
plot forward and we actually see
development with some of them more than
just the amount of ways they can sit on
the protagonist face we learn more about
the social structure and dynamics of the
monsters and the anti-demon core that
fight them inter family drama power
scalings Power Rankings tournament arcs
I'm going be real this story isn't going
to be winning Awards anytime soon but it
does everything it needs to it does just
enough to tickle that part of your brain
that wants to grab the popcorn and dumb
out to your typical Shonen action show
when you talk to a lot of anime fans and
the topic of guilty pleasures come up
you hear a lot of the same titles
getting thrown around High School of the
Dead High School DxD I've not talked to
a single person that have watched these
shows fully and don't talk about them
fondly they know what their appeal is
they know the target audience they're
aiming for and if you're not into these
types of shows they're not going to be
changing anyone's opinion but if you do
fall in that Target demographic if
you're fine fully embracing the sleeping
degenerate in you then this is like
eating McDonald's cooked by a three star
mellin Chef don't lie these aren't
guilty pleasures these are Pleasures you
feel no guilt enjoying they not only
fully commit to giving you the peak
gourmet fan service you've been craving
but respect you enough to know that you
still need more reasons to keep watching
once you hit postn Clarity you've come
that is M say no slave it knows what it
is and it devotes itself to being down
near the best product it can be for what
it's trying to achieve so if you want a
manga that does one thing and one thing
really well and that one thing is Being
Stepped On by powerful sexy military
clad anime girls with the added bonus of
a decent enough plot characters and
actually pretty damn good action then
mat SEO slave is the manga for you in
conclusion it should have been me not
[Music]
him hey guys hope you enjoyed that video
thank you very much this month too Alpha
Sigma ortha Curtis X basil dysfunctional
degenerate flabber Walky ivido lardos
misaka 12315 pain patchet Pony Stark
water Geist VT and everyone else on my
patreon for helping to support me for
this month and making this video
possible all right guys don't judge me I
know that recommendation might have
seemed a little horny
but I don't really know what to say
aside from that though if you didn't
know in about a week or two I'm going to
be touring Europe with trash taste yes
it is finally almost time so if you're
in Europe and you want a chance to meet
me this is your last chance to get
tickets our London show is already going
to be the biggest show we've ever done
and I heard there might be a little
special guest appearing on that show but
there are still tickets available since
it's by far our biggest venue we've ever
done so this is your last chance
trashtaste tour 23.com to get your
tickets today anyway though that's been
it for me for today I've been gig and
I'll see you all next time bye